النصر و رونالدو يجتاحني وسائل التواصل
عالمي»
اكبر خساره في التاريخ
وفيسبوك تبحث عوده ترمب الى مصرتها اهلا
بكم
[موسيقى]
اذا المشاهدين من يومين ونادي النصر
السعودي خاطف انظار العالم ومسيطر على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي في كل العالم
والسبب تعاقده مع النجم البرتغالي
كريستيانو رونالدو
بصفقه وصفت بتاريخيه خصوصا انه رونالدو
بيمتلك امكانيات رياضيه واقتصاديه كبيره
جدا تقارير اعلاميه كثيره حكت انه النصر
كسب افضل رياضي من الناحيه التسويقيه في
عام 2022 وما ننسى انه حاصل على الكره
الذهبيه خمس مرات وانه اول شخص في العالم
يصل الى 500 مليون متابع عبر شبكات
التواصل الاجتماعي واشياء كثيره بتميزه
وما في حدا بيقدر يتجاهلها اكثر من هيك
كمان مجله فورس كشفت انه الدولي البرتغالي
صار والرياضي في لعبه جماعيه بيتخطى
المليار دولار من اربعه خلال مسيرته
المهنيه واذا بنرجع بالتاريخ لورا شوي بس
لن واضح الموضوع اكثر واتعود الكترونالدو
للنادي الانجليزي مانشستر يونايتد ارتفع
سهم النادي بنسبه 8% وزادت القيمه السوقيه
بمقدار 212 12 مليون جنيه استرليني وبا
2018 كمان وقت ما وقع مع يوفنتوس سجلت
الايرادات التجاريه اعلى معدل نمو على
اساس سنوي بنسبه 30%
كلها يا جماعه ارقام جعلت رونالدو لاعب
نادي النصر السعودي يصنف على انه اكثر
الرياضيين قابليه لتسويق في العالم لعام
2022 متقدما على اسطوره التنس سيرين
واليامز في قائمه ضمت 50 رياضي بحسب سبورت
وبعد اعلان تعاقد رونالدو مع نادي السعودي
بدايق قليل شهدت حسابات نادي النصر
السعودي على منصات التواصل الاجتماعي زال
وقفزات هائله غير مسبوقه مسبوقه في اعداد
المتابعين بحيث ارتفع عدد المتابعين في
حسابه على منصه انستغرام لا يصل الى اكثر
من خمسه ملايين ونصف المليون متابع خلال
اقل من يوم وبلغ عدد عمليات الاعجاب على
بوسه الاعلان المنشور في منصه الانستغرام
اكثر من 30 مليون اعجاب وهو رقم كبير وغير
معتاد وعلى منصه تويتر كمان حصد التغريده
الاعلان تفاعل كبير على حساب نادي النصر
لدرجه شاهدها اكثر من 60
لون مغرد وحصلت على اكثر من 350,000 اعجاب
واكثر من 120,000 ريتويت واكثر من 53,000
منشن الموضوع بيستاهل صراحه خصوصا واللي
ما فينا ابدا ابدا انه النساء انه العربيه
فرده الخبر قبل الاعلان الرسمي وقرب الخبر
يحصل على نحو مليون مشاهده على حساب
العربيه مليونين مشاهدات على حساب العربيه
عاجل
اذا هذا الخبر بالفعل حصد اللي احنا
انفردنا فيه يعني في قناه العربيه حصل على
مشاهدات عاليه زي ما ذكرنا حوالي مليون
مشاهده و بالايام هذه لغه الارقام بتاكد
كل الاشياء ومن شوي حكينا عن هذا الموضوع
فعلى مستوى تسويق بيع قمصان الفريق يملك
رونالدو تاثير كبير كمان بهذا المجال وهذا
اللي صار فعلا باقبال مش طبيعي على متاجر
النصر للحصول على القميص ومن المتوقع ان
يسهم انتقال رونالدو الى النصر بجذب كوبرا
الشركات الاقتصاديه والتسويقيه بهدف
الاعلان عبر قميص النصر وملعقه اما بخصوص
انتقاله رونالدو للرياض فالمعلومات بتشير
الى انه راح يكون في العاصمه الرياض مساء
الثلاثاء بعد اقل من يومين وبحسب التوقعات
في مباراه الشباب
المقرره في 14 من شهر يناير راح تكون
الاولى للنجم البرتغالي مع فريق النصر
هلا مشاهدينا خلينا نشوف مع بعض جماهير
النصر كيف احتفلوا باعلان انضمام رولان
رونالدو لا فارس نجد والعالمي كما تطلق
عليه جماهيره
[موسيقى]
رونالدو
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا في الاستوديو الزميل الوحيد رزق
المصري رئيس تحرير اخبار الرياضه في قناه
العربيه اهلا بك وحيد معنا
خبر كثير هائل وكل هذا الزخم والحايك اللي
صار على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي وشفنا
قديش كمان جماهير النصر متحمسين وبرحبوا
رونالدو كيف راح تكون تبيعات همم انضمام
رونالدو لا النصر مش بس على النادي ولكن
على الكره السعوديه بشكل عام طبعا
في اول ايام العام الجديد طبعا صفقه
رونالدو
بمثابه الزلزال طبعا اكيد موجود كانت
الانباء والاشاعات ومن عده شهور انه
رونالدو يفاوضوا نادي سعودي بعد اصبح
الاسم هو نادي النصر ثم التوقي الرسميه
والعربيه انفردت انه اعلنت الخبر قبل
الصدور البيان رسمي يوم الجمعه
التبعات ستكون هائله اقلها مثل ما شاهدته
في السوشيال ميديا حساب نادي النصر قبل
رونالدو على انستغرام 800,000 تقريبا
متابع الان قبل ما ادخل 5 فاصل سته مليون
يعني عم نتكلم على تقريبا خمس ملايين في
24 ساعه رقم ابدا مش سهل في عالم السوشيال
ميديا والان هذا الاعتدافع وقوه وبيعطي
اشاره ايجابيه لاداره نادي النصر وادي
القائمين على نادي النصر والرياضه
السعوديه انه الصفقه رابحه منذ الان من
ناحيه التاثير الجماهير من ناحيه تاثير
اللي راح يكون على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي النصر قبل صفقه رونالدو والان
بعد صفقه رونالدو اكيد يوجد برنامج من
النصر من المسؤولين في الرياضه السعوديه
للاستفاده من وجود رونالدو في الملاعب
السعوديه رونالدو
اكيد طبعا رونالدو ليس غريب على الملابس
السعوديه لاعب هنا ما عندي سابقه كان في
مانشستر شارك وتواجد في الاراضي السعوديه
كان وجه اعلامي لبعض الشركات في السعوديه
سابقا لك الان واضح مختلف انت الان
رونالدو موجود عندك وبيحسب الاتفاق اللي
تم بنادي واللاعب سنرى كيف يتم الاستفاده
منه اهم نقطه طبعا في اللاعبين وعقودهم هي
الاجراءات اللي هي حقوق الصوره رونالدو
كان دائما حريص في عقود السابقه وهذا واحد
من اوجه الاختلاف اللي كانت بيني وبين
ريال مدريد بحسب وسائل الاعلام السابقه
انه هو يرغب بتكون حقوق الصوره كامل له
ممكن احتفظ بنفس الحقوق مع النادي النصر
لكن الاستفاده تكون بجوانب اخرى نادي
النصر الان اكيد الرؤيه همم التجاريه
والرؤيه اللي راح تكون عند اداره النادي
اعاده التفاوض على العقود الرعايه هذا هو
البنك
يا جماعه عالمي اهتمام اعلامي اكبر الدوري
نفسه رابطه الدوري الان ستجد اقبال اعلامي
اكبر عالميا طلب ملخصات المباريات
والفيديو اعتمادات صحفيين لحضور المباريات
والان عندنا مراحل اول شيء وصول رونالدو
للسعوديه هيكون حدث اول مؤتمر تقديم له في
مقر النادي سيكون حدث اخر كل هذا يمكن
الاستفاده منهم بيعده الصور او التدريب
بعدين او اللقاء ممكن يتم بث عبر قناه
النادي الاعلاميه او قنوات الاعلاميه اي
فيديوهات له في التدريبات وبعد ذلك ستاتي
الى اول مباراه ياخذها مع الفريق كل هذه
المحطات
شو بالنسبه للناحيه المعنويه همم انضمام
رونالدو لنادي سعودي مثل نادي النصر كيف
راح تاثر معنويا على همم اللاعبين
السعوديين بشكل عام همم على مشجعين الكره
السعوديه وهل يمكن كمان تفتح باب بلا نجوم
اخرين عالميين يجوا يلعبوا في السعوديه
طبعا السعوديه منذ قليل
العالميين رونالدو ليس اول اسم عالم ليصل
ووضعه الكره الذهبيه رونالدو الفائز
بالكره الذهبيه في البلغاري اللاعبه في
السعوديه وبالذات في نادي النصر وهو كان
بعد اربع سنوات من الحصول على البالون
الكره الذهبيه في عام اربع سنين 98 لاعب
مع نادي النصر انت الان تمتلك فرصه لتسويق
المسابقه تسويق النادي والاستفاده من وجود
هذا اللاعب اللاعبين سيجدو الى جانبهم شخص
ربما بعضهم كان يعتبره خلال البدايه في
كره القدم بعض منهم يراقبه كان في الملعب
او واجهه سابقا في مباريات وديه وما عندي
اخرى رونالدو يتميز بانه لديه تفكير
احترافي 100% يعني تدريب والالتزام باوقات
ونظام غذائي كل هذا سيكون
همم الاخرين حاولوا في النادي نظر له
والسير على خطواته والاقتداء به يعني ليس
اللاعب اللي همم خلينا نقولها بصراحه اللي
جاي في نهايه مسيرته وخلاص بده يرتاح
ويلعب ربع ساعه عشان دقائق او رونالدو
يلعب 90 دقيقه هذه واحده من الاسباب انه
هو في في سن متقدم بالنسبه لمقاييس كره
القدم لكن شخص وصل لهذه المرحله من حياته
وكان الوصول الماضي ايضا هداف نادي
مانشستر يونايتد رغم كل ممر به انه موسم
الحالي لكن اعتنى بنفسه جسديا ونفسيا
ودهنيا للوصول الى القمه والاستمرار فيها
وهما سيسال استمرار فيه في نادي النصر
ممكن يفتح الباب للاعبين سعوديين انهم
يلعبوا يحترفوا ويلعبوا عالمي يعني
الموضوع مختلف يعني اللاعب السعودي همم
اوروبيه لكن الموضوع مختلف الان البرامج
موجوده في السعوديه للاعبين الناشئين
برامج اعداد اللاعبين هناك برنامج تقوم
همم وزاره الرياضه برعايه منذ الوضع سنوات
وضع عده لاعبين شباب في قاره اوروبا مع
انديه مع اكاديميه يعني هذا ننتظر نتائجه
في المستقبل القريب يعني ليس ب- بمثل
سهوله جلب لاعب
لاجنبي لبناء يحتاج الى سنوات لكن اكيد ان
الكره السعوديه ستستفيد من وجود رونالدو
ومن حضوره الى السعوديه اكثر من اي مبلغ
مالي ممكن ان شاء الله شكرا جزيلا لك وحيد
رزق المصري زميلنا طبعا رئيس تحرير اخبار
الرياضه في العربيه شكرا
مشاهدينا فاصل قصير متابع بعده
اهلا من جديد
بشكل يومي لكن يبدو انه هالسنه كانت منيحه
ابدا ابدا عليه
شركه تسلا ايلون ماسك ثاني شخص في التاريخ
137 مليار دولار بس بعد التهاويسهم شركه
الاخيره هذا الانخفاض يا جماعه كان من ذره
ثروته البالغه 340 مليار دولار في الرابع
من نوفمبر 2021 بعد ما ضل اغنى شخص في
العالم عامين عموما ما بدنا نساوي اكيد
حسب التقارير اللي تكلمت عن الموضوع السبب
الرئيسي وراء اللي صار مع هو طبعا انشغاله
التام بتويتر بالفتره الاخيره واللي منذ
استحواذ ماسك عليه بيواجه تخبطاته وعواصف
ورياح من قراراته المفاجاه ثانيه واحده
خلت ماسك اول شخص يخسر 200 مليار دولار
بالتاريخ عموما يبدو ان سنه 2023 ما راح
تكون احلى للاسف على ماسك من 2022 والسبب
انه شركه تويتر بتواجه دعوه قضائيه للتخلف
عن سداد تخيلوا ايش ايجار مكتب لها في
مدينه سان فرانسيسكو بمبلغ تافه قياسيا
طبعا بثروه ماسك حتى مع انخفاضات تخيلوا
القضيه بتتعلق فقط ب 135,000 دولار مش
مليون الف دولار بالاضافه الى اموال
مستحقه لم تتفاعل تويتر لتاجيرها رحلتي
طيران شركه كولومبيا رايت الملكه للمساحه
المكتبيه المؤجره لشركه وتر رفع دعوى ايضا
قضائيه على الاخيره في منتصف الشهر الماضي
وعلى الرغم من الشركه الملكه لتويتر خمسه
ايام لدفع المبلغ لا الا انه تويتر لغايه
الان ما صدقتوا على كل حال نحكي اكثر عن
الموضوع معنا من الرياض عبد الله السبع
المحرر التقني في اندبندنت عربيه اهلا بك
يا عبد الله معنا في تفاعلكم يعني عنجد
شيء صعب انه ال الانسان يفهموا شركه تويتر
بجلاله قدرها والهن ماسك بالم 137 مليار
اللي بيملكههم مش قادرين يدفعوا 135,000
دولار يعني كيف نستوعب
لازم نعرف معلومه ان قيمه ثروت له الناس
ليست كلها اموال كاش انما بعضها اسهم
بعضها
اكثر من 155
بيبسي ان تويتر كيان مفصول عن له الناس في
الفلوس اللي موجوده عندي لا يعني انا اقدر
اصرفها على تويتر ايضا لازم نعرف معلومه
همم ان خلال الفتره الماضيه تويتر كانت
تمر بعده نيرات اشخاص فصلوا من مناصبهم
همم تغييرات جدا كثيره في التاثيرات من
هذا النوع شيء جدا طبيعي لان شركه ترى تمر
بتغييرات جدا كثيره وموظفين تقريبا فاصل
تقريبا ما يحضر لي الرقم لكن تقريبا ما
يقرب الخمسين في المئه الموظفين كانوا
موجودين هذا ممكن يزيد الضغط على الشركه
وممكن يخلي في ضعف بالتواصل ما بين
الشركات عدد كبير من الشركات همم
وزير التواصل مع تويتر فمثلا الى اي شركه
كان عندها مثلا علاقه مع تويتر كانت
تتواصل معها خلال سنوات الماضيه قد الان
تمر بفتره انها ما تقدر تتواصل معك تويتر
بسبب انها ما تعرف من الموظفين اللي
موجودين داخل شركه فلذلك الموضوع حق اجار
مكتبات وغيرها اتوقع انه راح يحل بفتره
جدا قريبه بسبب قله الموظفين وبسبب ايضا
عدم وجود اناس كثير في شركه بجانب تغييرات
الكبيره قاعده تمر فيها الشركه لازم نعرف
ان شركه غير جلدها بشكل كامل غيرت موظفين
فسرت موظفين جابت موظفين جدد فاسقاطات من
هذا النوع ومشاكل من هذا النوع جدا متوقعه
فما يعني يعني اكيد تويتر قادره راح تسدد
المبلغ خلال فتره جدا قريبه لكنه عادي ترى
جدا يعرفوني عليهم اجاره ههه بسبب منه
الموظفين اساس المكان موجودين وايضا بشكل
مختار القانوني شكله فما حدش عارف
بالموضوع
هو ممكن واحد سلمى وفصل من بكره ف ترى شيء
طبيعي جدا اللي قاعد تمر في فتره تويتر
واتوقع لانه حسب ما قرات انه كمان وصلت
تغيير الى الممثلين القانونيين وشغلات جدا
كثيره في فتره الماضيه
فالوضع طبيعي جدا واتوقع اني رحت حل هذه
المساله خلال الفتره قريبه لكنه الفتره
التي تمر فيها التويتر فتره صعبه جدا على
الجميع فكره صعبه جدا على المتعاقدين معها
فتره صعبه جدا على كمان مستخدمين تويوتا
يعني الاخبار اللي بتضلها تطلع عنق لهم
ماسك شو بيعمل عماله بتويتر تسريحه
الموظفين والقوانين الجديده وبعدين يعني
مرفوع عليها قضيه مبلغ تافه بغض النظر عن
الاسباب اللي كنا عم نتحدث عنها قديش هذا
بياثر على ثقه همم
مستخدمين تويتر
اول شيء لازم نعرف انه مستخدمين تويتر
حاليا شق متحمس جدا للمنصه وهذا ما ادى
الى زياده كمان اعداد المستخدمين في
المنصه ترى في الفتره الماضيه كانت في
طفره ونمو جدا كبير في اعداد المستخدمين
الجدد للمنصه لكن بنفس الوقت في ناس
مشتاقين من القرارات اللي قاعد تصير
مشتاقين لكل شيء لكن اذا رجعت لتجربه
المستخدم داخل المنصه المستخدم العادي
تويتر تحسن في الفتره الماضيه صار في تحسن
في تجربه المستخدم صحيح انك كانت في مشاكل
خاصه للمستخدمين عندنا في السعوديه قبل
تقريبا ثلاث اسابيع من راينا ثلاث اسابيع
صعبه اي احد يطلع من المنصور ما يقدر يدخل
عليها كانت في مشاكل تقنيه موجوده فيها
لكن المستقبل باذن الله راح لكم مشرق
لمنصه خاصه ان الان في تطلعات الى مشاريع
جديده تطلعات الى افكار جديده قد تضاف
للملف عكس السابق في السابق للاسف كنا
نسمع المشاكل تمر فيها المنصه عن اخبار
زائد حسابات وغيرها لكن انا وجهه الشخصيه
اتوقع ان المستقبل مشرق والمشاكل في
البدايه تكون وارده خاصه اذا كان في شخص
يشتغل ويحاول يغير الدماء داخل المنظومه
ان شاء الله يعني بنتمنى ذلك لانه من
الواضح بانه في كثير ناس مخلصين لهذه
المنصه لانه رغم همم يعني خروج كثير من
المص- منصات المشابهه لا العلن ولنور مثل
همم تنسوش او توتو وكمان بارلر وغيرها ما
قدروا يحققوا اي نجاح بالمقارنه همم تويتر
فاكيد يعني بنتمنى انه بالفعل همم
المستقبل يكون مشرق اكتر وانه يكون في
محله هي عبد الله شكرا جزيلا لك عبد الله
السبع المحرك العربيه
بعد عوده حساب ولا العمل على منصه الطائر
الازرق تويتر
يوتيوب
[موسيقى]
هذا مشاهدينا وصلنا لختام تفاعلكم مالي
هذا اليوم كل عام وانتم بخير والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]